اذا تنفذ روسيا اخيرا تهديدها بالرد على
القرار الغربي بتحديد سقف لاسعار نفطها
عند 60 دولارا للبرميل ما وصفت روسيا
بالاجراء العقابي تضمن حظرا تاما للتصدير
الى اي دوله او جهه تمتثل لهذا السقف
القرار كانت اتخذته مجموعه السبع بالتعاون
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي بدايه الشهر في اطار
المساعي لخفض قدره موسكو على تمويل حربيها
في اوكرانيا لتعيد موسكو اليوم رميه الكره
في الملعب الغربي فيما يبدو انه استمرار
لمعركه نفس الطويل بين الطرفين
في التفاصيل اذا وقع الرئيس الروسي في
نادي ليفربول قبل قليل مرسوما رئاسيا
بتدابير خاصه على خلفيه فرض عدد من الدول
سقفه اسعار للنفطر الروسي وفقا للمرسم
يحضر توريد النفط ومنتجاتهم من روسيا الى
الدول والجهات التي تفرض له سقفا سعريا في
العقود و سيدخل الحظر المفروض على توريد
النفط هو منتجاته من روسيا حيز التنفيذ
اعتبارا من الاول فبراير المقبل ويظل
ساريا حتى الاول من يوليو المقبل واشهر
المرسوم الى ان هذه تدابير تتدخل بشان ما
وصفها بالاجراءات غير الوديه والمخالفه
للقانون الدولي التي تتخذها الولايات
المتحده والدول الاجنبيه والمنظمات
الدوليه المرتبطه بها
حل هذا المرسوم اذا ينضم الينا من موسكو
مدير مكتب الجزيره زور شاوش ضانا في سوره
تفاصيل هذا المرسوم والذي نفذ فيها الرئيس
الروسي تهديداته
لاتفاق بين الدول الاوروبيه وايضا الدول
الصناعيه السابعه لوضع السقف لاسعار النفط
على رغم ان هذا سقف حدد ب 70 دولارا ايمان
واليوم روسيا فعليا ان نفطر
بحدود خمسه وخمسين دولار الى ان روسيا بكل
الاحوال بحسب الكريمه وبحسب كل تصريح سبقت
هذا المرسوم هي همم تعارض وضع حد السقف
الاسعار ليس لانها الان لديها خسائر
اقتصاديه او يمكن ان يكون لها خساره
اقتصاديه اذا اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار
الاسعار الان في الاسواق ولكن هي ترفضهم
من حيث المبدا ان همم الموقف الروسي مبني
بالدرجه الاولى على ان اسعار النفط اسعار
الطاقه بشكل عام تحددها قوانين السوق وليس
همم قرارات سياسيه تتخذها همم الدول همم
وفقا لمصالحها وهو في اطار عقوبات ضد وطرف
او ذات وبالتالي همم بوتين ذهب الى ما كان
منتظر منه ووقع مرسومه بانتظار مرسوم اخر
يتعلق بالتعامل ايضا بتصدير همم الغاز
ماذا يعني هذا هذا يعني ان روسيا ابتداء
من الاول من فبراير ستوقف تصدير النفط باي
شكل من اشكال العقود ان كان مع دول او مع
شركات اذا كانت هذه الشركات او هذه الدول
مرتبطه بقرارات تحديث سقف السعر الذي
تحدثت عنه الدول الغربيه او الذي توصلت
اليه بالنسبه لموسكو هذا سيؤدي طبعا الى
وقف همم تخفيض من الانتاج التحدث عنه نائب
رئيس الوزراء اليكساندر نوفال امس واول
امس بدنا نتوقع ان تخفض روسيا انتاجها
بحدود همم 500,000 الى 700,000 برميل
يوميا ولكن هذا لا يعني ان هناك خسائر
روسيه من الناحيه الماديه لان روسيا
ستستمر وستزيد من تصدير النفط الى الصين
والى الهند والدول جنوب شرق اسيا ومن
المتوقع ان هذا الاجراء روسي ربما نعرف
بعد ساعات قد يدفع الاسعار بالصعود الى
مستويات همم الكبيره هذا يعني ان روسيا
بكل الاحوال ستستمر بالحصول على حصتها من
عائدات النفط ربما لاحقا همم من عائدات
الغاز والكاميرون نحن امام ربما معطى جديد
في المواجهه السياسيه الاقتصاديه بين
روسيا والغرب رغم ان نعرف تداعياتها لاحقا
الجديده
بعد قليل شكرا لك من موسكو